thank you for giving me the opportunity
to present my work so this is jet work
with sean feat eva and undressing
xenovia so this talk will be about
assessing the prognostic power of
mutation profiles so it's a difficult
problem because as many people pointed
out this week most mutations or give at
a very low frequency and off for
patients share only few mutations in
common so for example on this line
cancer datasets must patient sure no
more than 60 mutations so that's makes
the task of predicting survival
difficult so I show I'll show you an
example of survival predictions with
TCGA exome sequencing data so real
binary data so you have patience time
genes binary matrix with survival times
for each patient and censoring
information so you know whether the
patient is deceased or not and then you
think to this data you predict survival
times so we model the survival with a
linear model of the mutation profiles
and we learn this linear function with
their ranking support vector machines
and the results we got are the following
so we perform the analysis with eight
different TCG data sets and we measure
the performance with the concordance
index so this index is between zero and
one and it gives you the percentage of
pairs of patients that were predicted in
accordance with the absurd survival time
and in accordance means that predicted
and the observed survival time agree on
which patients is going to live longer
so as you can see most cancers have
performances between 0.5 and point 55
knowing that point 5 is like a random
guess so it's not very good a point
maybe from kidney which is at 38 now if
we'd prefer to perform patient
stratification and see whether the sub
groups have different survivor times
well you would also have some problems
because what you hope you have is like
some beautiful clusters like this but
what you will get is well like that you
will get one very big cluster we where
you have almost all patients inside and
a few other clusters with one or two
patients inside so it's not working
either with the Rope mutation data so
what we want to do is to integrate the
binary mutation profiles with gene
networks to derive a new representations
of mutations which could yield improve
survival predictions and improve cancer
stratification okay so there is already
some work that has been done about that
and notably this work by Madonna friant
and co-authors which try it occurred
presented this morning so I'm just going
to repeat quickly what what they're
doing so the idea is that if two
mutations have no no mutations in common
they can have mutated son networks in
common so the idea is to propagate one
mutation in the network and in the end
you do this iteratively until it reaches
a stationary point and in the end every
gene is a value between zero and one
which represents how far it is from the
other mutations ok so you perform that
for propagation and then what they did
is that the performance I normalization
after each mutation profile was most
over the network okay so we got quite a
lot of inspiration from this right as
you will see
but first yeah we used this we apply
this procedure to the binary mutation
profiles and we predicted the survival
thanks to that so NSS network smoothed
mutation profile and n SQ n is network
smoothed with quanta normalization I'll
row is the raw data so as you can see
well it works pretty well you really
gained a lot of performance with that n
SQ n which is good but what we what we
did is we as you can see the
containerization really improve the
results so we try to investigate why
quant a normalization did really improve
their results so I try to explain this
was this a little picture so let's say
you have a patient a it's a binary
imitation profile and you smooth it over
the network so it's seen as a value
between 0 & 1 and then you sort the
mutation profile and you plot it in
increasing order so it gives you this
blue this blue profile so you see that
patient hey invasion a all these genes
were imitated but it's not fat all all
mutated genes to not have the same
mutation value and all this gene were
not mutated and we need the same thing
with the patient B which had more
mutations and what concern normalization
does is that it brings it normalized it
normalizes all patient to the same
distribution so here it's in a light
blue its overlaps with the red one and
what is the region which is interesting
is this one where you see that some
jeans that were mutated in patient be
end up with values here there are the
same as genes that were not mutated in
patient a and therefore you can see the
qn a little bit like removing removing
mutations from some patients while
adding mutations to others
okay so next to understand a little bit
better what was happening with an s qn
we we perform that word propagation but
this time only with one iteration only
and then did the containerization step
and what you can see when you do only
one iteration is that it does not
decrease the ladder results so it's it's
interesting because it means that when
you propagate a permutation averaging to
its neighbors only what you do not
really degrade your results so based on
these observations we designed a very
simple method which are we call net norm
which integrates also the networks with
the mutation profiles and it's done in
two steps a little bit like an SQL so
ranking and normalization so here the
ranking will be made as follows you rang
the mutated genes according to their
degree and you rank the non mutated
genes according to their number of
mutated numbers and you pay attention
that all mutated genes remain ranked
higher than normal date agents okay and
so this is a little bit equivalent to
your network smoothing step in the way
that it gives a ranking of jeans and
then we perform normalization by setting
to a 210 that one the gay genes that
have the highest mutation value and 20
the rest of the jit so to come back to
this picture it gives us like this kind
of stare profile where each patient's
end up with in k invitations so with
this method we perform the gain survival
predictions and as you can see it is
quite competitive force with a NS qn but
it's not so surprising because we
we never met norm has its own
normalization and its own rankings steps
as in neck next net worth losing rescuin
so yeah then we wanted to assess whether
for boss n SQ n on that norm whether
they that work really brought something
so we run we tested the method with
rundown networks so we re randomized the
networks by shuffling the jeans while
keeping the structure and changed so
here you see the results in green with
the real network and the 10 I gray plots
are with a randomized version of the
network and as you can see the
performance are better with real network
and it is it is significantly better
according to a wash t-test between the
the green and the grave plots so it says
that even if we only look at the
infamous at the information contained in
the neck birth of a gene but this
information in this information there is
something that's biologically important
okay yeah and to finish we apply to all
of these representations to perform a
patient stratification so we obtain
subgroups of patients and then we tested
whether at least two of these subgroups
at different survivals with a log-rank
test so this is the la quinta statistics
in the y-axis and on the x-axis you see
the number of subgroups that we tested
so for the lung cancer data sets you see
ya well under one circle means that the
law grim statistics was significant like
under five percent
and drew circles mean and the one
percent so you see that for lung cancer
data sets net norm app gives sub groups
which have different survival outcomes
and in the case of melanoma the door net
norm against give significant groups but
also an sqn for cake was for and for a
higher number of suburbs you see that if
you only take the number of mutations as
the only information to stratify
patients you also get subgroups with
survivals that are even more significant
different so yeah to finish with what we
wanted to show what i wanted to show in
this talk is that for a survival
prediction in using networks really
helps gaining having better performances
and there is a biological information in
a network that's useful i also that
restricting the mutations in not to
diffuse only to the neighbors it's
sufficient to you have good accuracy and
that normalizing the mutation profiles
is a crucial step to have good
performance well thank you for your
attention questions
so the only question I have about the
the revised method that you presented
was I would be I would be a little
worried about the hub pneus of a node in
the network it's really seeing the it's
a ring yeah chances yeah so totally yeah
yeah well you're right because it's the
case herbs are really you have more
absorb moma dated in the end and the
other genes but what seems to happen is
that the mutational burden in the
nectars of the app is actually
predictive of survival
you're right about that
yeah so for your first point that only
doing one iteration of your random wat
didn't see it worse than your results
very much that across a range of restart
parameters are just fruit for a more
narrow range so you have a a recent
grand interfere there's random on the
right yeah so like controls locality the
random walk in a sense right yes I the
it was performed several times with
different values of alpha which is the
parameter that controls how far you go
yeah so yes it was performed several
times for larger values I would expect
that you you wouldn't see necessarily
much of a difference because you're
gonna stay close to your you're going to
restart very top than anything but first
of all our values I'd imagine more yeah
but um
I know if yeah but the random walk
happens when you do the whole process of
iterating until your riches as you reach
a stationary point but what we do when
we have only one iteration it's just at
the neck Barbra jeans will receive a
certain eat and there's no random walks
anymore you just receive it the head of
your network and that's yen sure if I
I'm sorry